château gonflable toboggan ou encore
poney les familles et les jeunes de la
ville de Coignières ont pu dès ce samedi
profiter des animations organisées par
la mairie un événement essentiel pour
les habitants selon le maire Didier
Fisher c'est très apprécié des jeunes et
des familles parce que c'est un moment
vous le voyez convivial ou les parents
viennent avec leurs enfants et ça se
passe bien il y a des jeux il y a des
structures gonflables c'est devenu un
rendez-vous incontournable et il
l'attendent il l'attendent comme vous le
dites tout à l'heure tout le monde part
pas en vacances malheureusement donc
c'est un peu des vacances quoi en plus
des animations organisées en journée les
quais ni rien peuvent profiter de soirée
à thème comme la soirée Dj magicien ou
encore barbecue pour les familles le
succès semble déjà être au rendez-vous
par rapport à d'autres choses qu'on a pu
voir dans d'autres villes je trouve que
c'est très bien c'est très encadré dès
que je peux oui je viens c'est quelque
chose qui permet à la communauté de se
retrouver les enfants vu qu'ils se
connaissent tous à l'école donc
forcément ils se retrouvent leurs
copains copines un événement festif et
convivial qui se tient jusqu'au 16
juillet au gymnase du moulin à vent à
Coignières